Megan's been blamed for the rift at the
heart of Windsor and four four megsit
but actually you know was she just the
Catalyst that Harry needed to get out
she was included in mentioning King
Charles's first speech to the nation I
want also to express my love for Harry
and Megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas do you foresee I know there's a
lot of hypotheticals and speculations
here that we are having to make but
could you see King Charles embracing her
and having her be a part of the monarchy
more well you know Charles actually
always had a pretty good relationship
with with Megan it was Camilla who
suggested that Charles walked Megan up
the aisle and of course he did I think
it was a very proud moment for him I
mean they enjoyed holidays in Scotland
together it you know it went really
wrong really quickly because actually
Charles was sort of very supportive of
them in the early days of the courtship
stepped in on on the wedding day when of
course Thomas Michael couldn't be over
here and I think he feels quite
heartbroken by how it has spiraled
downwards so quickly and I think he is
Keen to to repair that relationship what
do you know about Harry and Megan's
return to the US after the Queen's death
well they were certainly a major part of
the of the the days leading up to the
Queen's funeral I mean we saw them on
that Walkabout in Winter and I think
every effort was made to include them as
much as possible I mean we saw Megan in
the car with with Sophie the Countess of
Wessex you know the concessions were
made so that Harry could be in his
uniform the only time really I suppose
they were demoted was when they weren't
at the state reception the night before
the funeral but that's because they're
not working members of the royal family
right but I think there was a clear
message you're in as family but in terms
of working Royals you're not you're out
and the queen made it very clear that
you were either in or out and so I think
they probably returned to California
with very mixed emotions grief possibly
some regret over how things had panned
out I mean don't forget that Harry and
Megan were invited to go to Balmoral to
spend a weekend with the queen with
their children in that summer they chose
not to go and so it must have been with
heavy hearts but I think also a sense of
disappointment of anger I mean Harry
didn't look happy do you think King
Charles will force an amendment between
the brothers well I I think it's very
difficult for for the king to force a
Reconciliation on anyone it's either
going to happen or or it's not and and
we know that you know Charles did have
some conversations with Harry while he
was over there that there is this
flicker of hope that there can be a
Reconciliation it is his genuine hope
that he can smooth things out
foreign